podríamos decir que estas
manifestaciones Más allá de rechazar el
caso específico de masa a mini reflejan
el hartazgo generalizado de la población
a décadas de represión
buenas tardes y muchas gracias por la
invitación si estás protestas tienen una
diferencia abismal con otras que se han
presentado en años anteriores Y es que
están pasando de una protesta por
digamos el la ley que hay desde 1983 del
Código de vestimenta de las mujeres a
reunir Y eso se está viendo Precisamente
en el hecho de que están avanzando las
protestas desde Teherán ya en más hay 31
provincias en Irán y ya hay más de 19
provincias hay protestas los hombres se
han Unido y gente de todas las clases
sociales esto se explica por qué Porque
Irán está sufriendo en este momento unos
niveles de hiperinflación ya vamos en el
50% unos niveles de pobreza enormes y
hay un desgaste ya del
régimen y de la Revolución frente a
todos frente a la respuesta que puede
dar a estos temas además tenemos que ya
había habido estas protestas antes en el
2017 en el 2019 tuvimos algunas
protestas en contra del uso del velo
pero el otro elemento es que teníamos en
la presidencia al Señor Luján y que era
moderado en este momento subió al poder
desde agosto del 2021 raíz y que es un
ultraconservador que además se perfila
se perfila para hacer el nuevo ayatolá
en el entendido que el ayatolá jamedini
ya es una persona que tiene 83 años
ahora varias ong y activistas hacen un
llamado a la comunidad internacional
Para apoyar mecanismos para atender la
crisis de Derechos Humanos en Irán
Cuáles podrían ser estos mecanismos por
ejemplo
Pues digamos que ya ha habido unos
apoyos internacionales a los movimientos
sabemos por ejemplo que Estados Unidos
digamos limitó las restricciones que
había sobre el uso de internet para que
los protestantes puedan empezar a subir
vídeos imágenes de lo que está pasando
en Irán y evidentemente vamos a tener y
ya hemos tenido algunos pronunciamientos
en materia de derechos humanos y el
respeto a los Derechos Humanos sobre
todo por las últimas declaraciones que
se han dado sabemos que en Irán quienes
controlan las protestas son los guardias
revolucionarios Y en este momento ya el
presidente ha dicho que las fuerzas se
van las fuerzas militares se van a
encargar también de controlar estas
protestas Entonces es probable que haya
una escalada en los enfrentamientos y
como sabemos Normalmente se empieza a
decir que esto está infiltrado por los
extranjeros